see what this excuse is still there they
go waiting bear man we've been here for
an hour I don't make a stop
what's that what's that this is my
business is what it is show us come on
I'm not show you nothing do you
understand what's going on today guys
tell us I am going it's a legendary
Ben's Chili Bowl God you're know who
else has been here a bunch of black
leaders okay Ike who Malcolm X dr.
Martin Luther King
- what's the guy with uh the gene that
got the jacket dimension Barack Barack
Obama he never wears jeans brother you
don't know him like I know him I've seen
him a gene sometimes better line these
are all black men that are changing the
world looks to me like another black
leader is walking in this place that
needs to be recognized you do stand-up
you're not a black leader this man out
of black leader Harry don't do this huh
show me that right there you got a pitch
him huh I got what I got is history okay
and it's placing me in here you know
Barack Obama's on his way out the office
sounds to me like this face on wall just
opened up care you're not gonna go in
here and ask them to put you on the wall
damned if I won't did they ask you to
bring your Pig ain't about to ask is
about what you want don't do this I'm
doing it don't do it don't believe don't
do this don't okay I don't do